kal-el my future grandson this is the
story of the house of Belle this belongs
to your grandson kal-el hey everybody is
Charlie so we finally got our Superman
TV show back on TV and it's actually way
more hardcore than I expected they
really went all out for this it's gonna
be 10 episodes total so if you are
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos
obviously most of the Easter eggs
they're pulling are from the DC cosmic
universe and pretty much anything from
Superman comics so let's do top 10 WTF
like I would normally do and there's
like extra Easter eggs because this is
the first episode so I'll just try to
break it up as I go along starting with
number 10 the setting is Kandor city
which immediately sets off warning bells
in everyone's heads like oh my god a lot
of the series is based on the characters
from the world of Krypton comic book
series which was a limited run like
there was a Dan Jergens run that
actually introduced the seg l character
so he's the main character the series
that sees about 23 years old so he's
like Clark's age when he hit metropolis
when he was still the red-blue blur
before he started wearing the Cape so
like right around the last couple of
seasons of Smallville us about how old
he is and if you're wondering why
they're all British they filmed this in
the UK they wanted Kryptonians to read
as British because it's a nice
counterpoint to the farm boy that Clark
Kent is growing up in Midwestern Kansas
so they wanted Kryptonians to feel like
an ancient race that was also very
different from the place that Superman
grew up so that's why the British and
you probably recognize some of the main
actors too like Siegel's father is
played by the constable from the
Sherlock series his grandfather is Sir
Barristan Selmy from Game of Thrones
who pops up in a bunch of different
British series remember it films in the
UK so you'll probably see a lot of
familiar faces if you watch a lot of UK
series number 9 the death of his
grandfather so there's a lot that's
going on here like you look it the way
everybody's dressed there's this really
drab colors Gray's blacks Browns he's
the only one that's dressed in what you
would think of is traditional Kryptonian
garb like when you look at New Krypton
or any of the times that Booster Gold
has taken Superman back to Krypton's
history everybody has all these bright
colors that pop all over the place it
looks like they have this great cultural
Renaissance that's not happening right
now
because they're entering that time in
their history that they talked about
during that Man of Steel prequel or
artificial population control was
established the outposts and space
exploration were abandoned exhausted our
natural resources where they stopped
looking to the Stars where they started
over mining their planet that eventually
led to their destruction although now we
have that Terminator twist of the series
where you have Brainiac coming back into
the past seeming like he's trying to
speed that along so that it's
potentially easier for the Brainiac of
this time period to collect Krypton the
really cool thing that happens is they
opened the episode with the John
Williams theme or a bit of a remix
version of it that comes back around at
the end of the episode when they pull
out Superman's cape but also as his
grandfather's being executed he says
keep believing in a better tomorrow the
Easter Egg there is that Superman is
known as the man of tomorrow that's even
the rumor title for the Man of Steel
sequel or at least the one that
everybody hopes that they title it
there's also a bit of a Star Wars new
hope twist where the Senate like the
ruling council is disbanded the way that
they disband the Old Republic Council
and it becomes the Empire the Emperor so
to speak the voice of rail that wears
that golden helmet that doesn't let you
see what he actually looks like is
probably gonna turn out to be something
of a villain I'm expecting a couple
twists but I'll explain because it sort
of ties in with what I think Brainiac
from the future is doing by coming back
into the past
the ridiculous premise that you're asked
to accept is that Kryptonians don't
believe that there's other life out
there which seems kind of silly because
they're a relatively advanced race so I
think you just have to accept the idea
that their society has become so
dominated by religious dogma that over
centuries it's gotten to the point where
it is now it's not an overnight thing
that just happened but like the fortress
of solitude that his grandfather hid out
in the wilds that has existed for a long
time he wasn't the person to build that
that's been in his family for
generations
number eight doomsday Easter Egg if you
guys didn't pick up on it when they're
doing the training session with the
house of Zod you basically have let
Assad's mother telling them about all
the dangers that will befall them and
why they the military guild the
Sagittarii
are meant to protect Kryptonian society
she mentions the other city-states so
like Argo city is another big city-state
on Krypton that's where Supergirl is for
so eventually I wouldn't be surprised if
in a future season or later this season
we bump into some of supergirls
ancestors but remember this is 200 years
set in the past so we actually wind up
seeing any of the characters from
present day or versions of them it'll be
some crazy time-travel explainer she
also says beasts of the wild so the
thing about the wild is is that doomsday
is actually a beast of the wild that was
created to survive Krypton's harsh
environment so they give you a little
taste of that when they leave the city
to go find the fortress of solitude the
first time you see the ruins of this
outer city like there used to be
something going on here maybe there was
some apocalypse some implied history
something terrible happened so they'll
probably spell that out to the course of
the series so the producers did confirm
that they would do a version of doomsday
at some point but it'll be the comic
book Dan Jergens version where you
actually get to see him evolve like a
scientist actually created doomsday the
one you saw during Batman V Superman is
sort of like a backdoor clone created by
Lex Luthor using the science that was
stored on the Kryptonian ship not the
actual doomsday but number 7 welcome to
Krypton Adam Strange the Detroit Tigers
hat was a nice touch that's just to let
you know that he's from present-day
consider him as being from like 2018 but
he's basically come into the past
because he's learned about brainiacs
plan in the future so when he comes back
but then disappears that's because the
Zeta beam technology only allows him to
be in the past for brief periods so
that's why he's going to be jumping in
and out of the series as we get through
the episodes but because with him he
brings a lot of the ran thanagar
mythology we will eventually meet Hawk
world Hawkman Hawkgirl stuff they did
say they'll be doing those characters on
the TV series
so like when Siegel's grandfather says
that there are threads out there he was
mostly talking about Brainiac but there
are also other systems there's the daksa
mites
there's ran thanagar there's the
dominators pretty much any space-based
villain race that you could imagine from
the Superman comics so with either
slowly dipping their toe in that water
but there are many many threats as they
say during the episode beyond Brainiac
it's just that first things first this
is all about introducing the threat of
Brainiac and his plan to Terminator
style changed the past but number six
discovering the fortress of solitude so
obviously they're using a version of the
Man of Steel logo it's a
little bit different but they're all
pulling from that Man of Steel mythology
because it's David Goyer David Goyer is
the person that wrote the Man of Steel
movie he's the one that personally did
that Krypton pre sequence so a lot of
this mythology that he teed up with the
Man of Steel movie was the basis for the
Krypton series he uses the key to open
it it's a nice reference to Superman's
key that he just leaves out in plain
sight of that super dense metal that
only he can pick up
[Music]
but the whole idea is is that now that
he's discovered it he's gonna start
activating all these systems we'll
probably find a whole bunch more Easter
eggs this is really just the first look
at it number five the Brainiac reveal so
they tell everybody flat out what's
going on there is something out there
called Brainiac he devours worlds so
remember this is a time travel series
but Brainiac evolves over time meaning
that the architect of this Terminator
style plan is Brainiac from the future
the Brainiac of the past is still going
around the universe collecting systems
albeit he's not quite as powerful as the
Brainiac of the future without as much
knowledge so early speculation what
might be happening is this Brainiac from
the future comes back to the past to try
and create circumstances that make it
easier for his past self to collect
Krypton so that's why I'm wondering if
the person underneath that gold mask is
just another version of Brainiac just
pretending to be the voice of rau or
somebody who's in league with Brainiac
helping to bring about the collection of
Krypton next big one number four black
zero so big name drop both a person and
an organization in the comics the
reference on the TV show is mostly to
the organization they're a group of
terrorists that are actually responsible
for the destruction of Krypton so they
might be changing the backstory just a
little bit because when the mother says
that she's part of black zero it sounds
like she's just saying that so that
they'll throw her under the bus and she
can sacrifice herself and save her son
but it's also possible because she seems
like she has some crazy secret skills
that she was keeping on the DL that she
may have been part of black zero at some
point but they've cast people for that
storyline will actually meet black zero
eventually on the TV show if we haven't
already met them but a lot of their
ideals are mostly for the betterment of
Kryptonian society like they're all
about clone rights there's a lot of
crazy genetic science that they
experiment with on Krypton like we
visited the Genesis chamber which is
like a whole other story line that's
going on but doomsday was created
through creative genetics so black zero
is all about rights for the
underprivileged so they might be using
that for this lower unkilled at caste
that might be how they rise up on the TV
show but in the comics they detonated
something called the destroyer in
Krypton's core and that's what blew up
Krypton but that's
like the pre-crisis version of the
comics so I don't know how they're gonna
change that for the TV show like it just
all sounds like they're gonna blame
Brainiac for everything bad that happens
to Krypton now but number three is
parents sacrifice himself so you kind of
see they're creating the circumstances
that make him sort of a parallel for
what's going on with Superman Superman
is an orphan he needs to spend time by
himself he goes to the fortress of
solitude seg L loses his parents he
needs to be alone he goes to his
Fortress of Solitude
so he has to sort of learn to be the
kind of person that Superman will
eventually become over the course of the
series be the hero of his planet the way
that Superman becomes the hero of the
earth the thing about this though is
that they sort of layer in this level of
politics this game of Thrones aspect to
it where you have houses that have
warring interests so allure azad who
executes both of his parents actually
seems like she was helping them
accomplish their goal like she didn't
want to kill them but recognize that if
they had been captured then they would
have given up the vital information
that's probably going to be needed by
either black zero or the people that are
gonna try and stop Brainiac and I'm just
gonna call her Zod for the sake of
simplicity even if Zod doesn't really
agree with what the house of El was
doing she doesn't like what the ruling
council is doing or the voice of rau she
wants to protect Krypton so I wouldn't
be surprised if she winds up helping seg
el and they're also sort of changing
cannon just a little bit they did say
that because it's a time travel show
Terminator Sarah Connor Chronicles style
things that they do now could
potentially edit things that happen
later so for instance he's in that
relationship with Lita Zod it's totally
possible that because they don't want to
marry the people that they've been bound
to that they have a biological child
together that is jor-el and they sort of
tie the house of Zod to the house of El
long-term in a way that they haven't
been before so imagine they do something
like that then you rewatch Man of Steel
or you watch any of the Superman movies
and it becomes jor-el versus Zod they
would actually be related much more
closely by blood number two like I said
though the voice of rau sort of
listening in when they're talking about
the actual location of the fortress did
you find it oh I didn't see you standing
there your high honor what possible
reason could they have for not wanting
to reveal what he looks like the whole
thing about that is that we've seen what
a version
Braniac looks like from the future
that's what the ship looks like when
Adam Strange is talking about it but we
don't know what Brainiac looks like
during this time period but I do like
the idea that the house of vex like this
person the chief administrator looks
exactly like the classic version of Zod
and his daughter kind of gives off an
Ursa vibe like she's sort of like the
Cersei or Margaery Tyrell of the show
the big one though number one Adam
Strange comes back with Superman's cape
they play the John Williams theme again
he gives him the mission you must stop
Brainiac protect your grandson protect
the chance for the better tomorrow that
his grandfather referenced when he was
killed at the beginning of the episode
so I'm sure there's a couple of
questions about the mythology just ask
them below in the comments there's like
a whole bunch of other stuff during the
episode like the houses the culture that
we can talk about as we get through the
episodes but just everybody let me know
what you thought of it so far but I
almost forgot the Cape that he gives him
everybody's been asking about the symbol
because it doesn't look like Henry
cabals Man of Steel logo even though a
lot of the series is designed to look
like it's part of that Man of Steel
mythology the Cape that he's wearing is
actually the cloth cape the Christopher
Reeve wore if they do wind up doing
Superman on the TV show it'd probably be
something that they would save for the
finale like some sort of flash-forward
or he gets a vision of what his grandson
will eventually look like they'll find
some way to reference that but for the
most part the cape serves as the Back to
the Future style photo like it sorely
fades as things get worse and worse and
worse so it's the reminder of the
ticking clock and I almost forgot
speaking of you know other things going
on in the universe there is a legion
ring that I'm giving away as part of
this like I do the flash ring giveaway
is on my flash videos I'll do Legion
rings for the Krypton videos so for the
most part I think these will be Thursday
morning videos the only reason this
didn't post earlier just because of that
Deadpool trailer drops so early but
click here to rewatch that Deadpool
trailer and click here for brand new
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]